the Joe Rogan experience so Wow we
should tell everybody what we learned
today I'm revising my thinking about
this virus because of Michael yo Michael
yo caught it Michael yo is healthy as
[ __ ] he's he's not he's not any
high-risk group like he's not he doesn't
have any pre-existing conditions he's in
shape and he got it and he got pneumonia
too and he said it was a double
combination and he thought he was gonna
die and he was in the hospital for over
a week and four days ago he said he
thought he was gonna die
that's [ __ ] terrifying cuz Michael yo
is healthy he's not some 80 year old man
I talked to my friend dr. Peter TIA
he's a physician and he swam from
momwhat Maui yes he swam all the islands
he's a [ __ ] straight-up savage so his
take this is my question to him
I said this is crazy [ __ ] what is your
take on how so many people experience
very few symptoms but others get wrecked
and he said I still think most people
below 55 sail through it I've had two
patients get it
shitty cold and loss of a sense of smell
and taste which probably returns soon
but still a small fraction of these
folks get hurt I know a doctor of a 28
year old fitness instructor on a
ventilator in New York City today why he
said maybe some genetic predisposition
we know blood types matters a is the
worst Oh is the best based on antibodies
Sam
he said I'm all positive he said but I
don't think that explains more than some
of it maybe [ __ ] like vaping he said
still too soon to tell he is a straight
up no nonsense no [ __ ] guy and I
listen to everything he says
so when guys like him are concerned I
get concerned and he's concerned he's
had a weird disease another thing that
he said it's weird that it seems that
people who spend more time with this get
it worse he's like it's not like you
know like like doctors and hospitals
with prolonged exposure get it really
bad nurses
in hospitals with prolonged exposure
seem to get it really bad whereas some
people get it and they don't get it bad
it's weird it's a very very strange
disease according to doctors and I think
we're still trying to figure this out
you know it's just wow it's it's one of
those things where everyone's just sort
of absorbing the information as it comes
in and you got to be open to adjusting
your opinions my opinions were I really
was concerned with old people and I was
concerned with sick people
now after Michael Young I'm like okay
this is not that straightforward there
might be some some other crazy factors
here like for some people yeah like
Idris Elba who looks fantastic you know
fine but maybe other people are gonna
have a real hard time with it like
Michael yo Michael he was not sickly guy
he's a big robust guy that's a spooky
one yeah I mean your podcast with the
osterholm chicle it Chicken Little that
scared the [ __ ] out [ __ ] sitting in
the back of my tour bus and then hear
this I'm like ah I've had a few
cocktails I had a joint let's go to bed
oh cool who's this guy ah the
coronavirus I would mind hearing a
little bit about that
oh holy first thing I did I told Jamie
first thing I did i sat up in bed and I
was googled that [ __ ] I was like
you wrote a book didn't he [ __ ] that guy
like I was guys I was so freaked out in
that [ __ ] podcast what's crazy about
osterholm is he predicted this [ __ ]
literally specifically as to where it
was gonna come from
he was very insightful you mean [ __ ]
that guy in a bad way very insightful
dude it was a great podcast but man it's
I'll tell you right now Joe you said you
said so guys that are overweight the
drink a lot the smoke I was talking to
you you know that right by the way I
thought you were I'm talking to you I
didn't want to say it but I was like
piecing together at all my good friends
who's my one for him to taste care of
himself the worst it's you is me
[Applause]